bénédiction me porter patrie et filles
expirent sans qu'ils se dotent super u
ou sept manades semper
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir on ne peut plus détruire l'homme
il n'est pas permis de l'humilier il
n'est pas permis de le haïr fait aux
hommes de bonne volonté
voilà le message que jean paul ii a
lancé aujourd'hui à midi au monde entier
avant de venir la foule place et qui
étaient massés place saint-pierre et
quelques 500 millions de téléspectateurs
qui suivaient la cérémonie dès la nuit
dernière le saint-père qui célébrait la
messe de minuit à saint pierre de rome
avait recommandé que l'on pense d'abord
à ceux qui sont victimes de l'inhumanité
il est vrai que cette trêve de noël a
été ternie par des drames et des
violences beyrouth la turquie l'iran ou
l'inde
la nuit dernière c'est devant une
assemblée de fidèles particulièrement
nombreuse que jean paul ii a célébré la
première messe de noël de son pontificat
le saint père a regretté de n'avoir pu
en cette occasion se rendre dans la
grotte de la nativité à bethléem puis
dans son homélie le pape a invité tous
les chrétiens à penser à ceux qui sont
seuls âgés malades à ceux qui n'ont pas
de logement qui souffrent de la faim et
dont la misère est une conséquence de
l'injustice des systèmes de communes
jean paul ii a eu également une pensée
pour ceux qui at-il dit faute de prêtres
s'ils n'ont pu participer à la liturgie
de la nativité
à jérusalem juifs et chrétiens ont fêté
ensemble noël qui coïncide cette année
avec la fête juive des lumières la
hanouka c'est un long cortège que la
foule est venue se recueillir devant le
mur des lamentations et la cérémonie a
pris une signification particulière
puisque plusieurs centaines de juifs
récemment immigrées d'union soviétique
il participait à quelques centaines de
mètres de là dans la citadelle de la
vieille ville
une veillée de prière était organisée
pour le liban noël à pékin a été marquée
par un petit événement pour la première
fois depuis 1949 la télévision chinoise
a présenté hier soir un programme de
musique religieuse et on a remarqué
aussi que les fidèles assistant la messe
de minuit ont été plus nombreux que
d'habitude
noël en france et bien la tradition a
été respectée les réveillant famille les
rues vides les fidèles nombreux se
rendant messe de minuit mais dans
certains endroits la fête a été marquée
d'une gravité inhabituelle
il s'agit des régions touchées par le
chômage ou les évêques ont tenu à
rappeler les difficultés de milliers de
familles ainsi monseigneur bernard
évêque de nancy célébrant la messe en
plein bassin sidérurgique de l'ong oui a
dit dans son homélie
dieu veut que nous vivions le plus
pleinement possible c'est pourquoi nous
devons lutter pour qu'il y ait de
l'emploi pour que les hommes soient
respectés et puis cette nuit de noël a
été marquée par un drame horrible à
vernouillet dans les yvelines
un homme de 49 ans un cadre commercial a
battu pendant leur sommeil
sa femme et ses trois enfants âgés de
dix neuf et six ans et s'est suicidé
après avoir appelé la police avant de
mourir elle a laissé une lettre disant
qu'ils risquaient d'être licenciés et
qui ne supportait pas de devenir chômeur
le patron de ce cadre commercial a
précisé ce soir qu'il n'était pas
question de licenciements
il avait simplement changé de situation
à l'intérieur de l'entreprise qui semble
également que ce père de famille était
depuis un certain temps très déprimée ce
qui avait amené déjà à des gestes
inconsidérés
bien entendu une enquête a été ouverte
autre fait divers à nice à la brasserie
restaurant le may fair dont
l'international de football jean marc
guillou capitaine de l'ogcnice est l'un
des gérants
et bien cette brasserie a été incendiée
la nuit dernière d'après la police il
s'agit d'un incendie
mina à l'étranger deux pays ont connu au
cours de ce week-end des violences et
des émeutes qui ont fait plusieurs
dizaines de victimes
il s'agit de l'iran et de la turquie en
iran ce week end a encore été marquée
par des heurts sanglants entre soldats
et manifestants
il y aurait plus d'une cinquantaine de
morts à téhéran mechhed et tabriz dans
la capitale iranienne ces manifestations
au pris un tour très nettement étaient
américains ce matin les manifestants ont
envahi le centre de la ville pour donner
l'assaut à l'ambassade des états unis
l'armée a ouvert le feu le chef de
l'opposition monsieur panjabi a pour sa
part demandé à nouveau aujourd'hui au
chat de quitter le pouvoir en turquie
les émeutes survenues samedi et dimanche
ont quant à elles fait au moins 98 morts
et 145 blessés à caraman maras dans
l'est du pays les émeutes avaient débuté
vendredi soir à l'occasion des obsèques
de deux enseignants militants de gauche
assassiné par un commando de droite
malgré le couvre-feu et l'arrivée des
parachutistes les incidents ont repris
hier dimanche après que des éléments de
droite est attaqué les quartiers
progressiste ce soir une nouvelle
fusillade à l'armé automatique a éclaté
dans la ville où plusieurs secteurs ont
été bouclés par la troupe pour le
président sadate le problème de la paix
au proche orient n'en est plus un après
accords de camp david
le chef de l'état égyptien répéter ce
soir que la paix interviendrait tôt ou
tard monsieur sadate a fait cette
déclaration à la télévision à l'occasion
de son 60e anniversaire noël à beyrouth
les chrétiens du quartier d'achrafieh
ont tenté de donner un air de fête à
cette partie de la ville très touchée
par les bombardements d'octobre mais
c'était sans grand enthousiasme
beyrouth est devenue une ville qui fait
mal au coeur peu avant noël betty dureau
et jean le berre ont promené une caméra
d'antenne 2 dans les rues de la capitale
libanaise
ils ont ensuite projetées les images à
des petits français à des élèves d'une
classe de 8e qui auront la chance de
connaître la paix les enfants ont parlé
leurs réflexions valent toutes les
dissertations du monde
freins
beyrouth aujourd'hui c'est ce spectacle
celui d'une ville assassiné y avait des
maisons complètement ravagé des murs
défoncés tout ça je comprends pas
pourquoi ils s'attaquent aux innocents
ils devraient s' attaquer les ennemis à
ceux qui portent des armes à ceux qui
font la guerre
les enfants ils n'y sont pour rien c'est
pas de leur faute s'il ya une guerre
c'est les hommes qui font ça et de toute
façon une guerre ça c'est se servir à
rien c'est pas parce qu'on fait une
guerre que ça va ça va arranger les
jours si on en fait quelqu'un par
exemple et qu'on veut se défendre ont
jeté faille après l'autre il voudra
encore se défendre ça continuera comme
ça toujours
rihanna qui sont pour quelque chose on
n'a qu'à me sens pas essayé à la news on
est tranquille
une route c'est aussi cela des hommes en
armes partout là des palestiniens pour
un meeting présidé par yasser arafat
nous sommes à beyrouth-ouest le quartier
musulman
com
12 ans leur donne un fusil pour
remplacer ceux qui sont moins tout le
tout le monde est presque à leur pays
quand ils ont un fusil chez lagon de
garde et e
il trouve ça formidable mais les mois je
serai alors pas je n'aimerais pas porter
un fusil si les parents ne donne pas
l'exemple aux enfants des enfants vont
suivre
si la viola au cinoche moins cher dirais
pour nourrir un autre visage de beyrouth
celui des gens qui ont faim dans le
quartier chrétien d'abord écrasé par les
bombes
puis bouclé par les syriens ceux qui
sont restés achrafié lives au jour le
jour les gens riches où ils ont une
belle maison et où ils sont presque
jamais attaqué mais les gens pauvres qui
sont dans la ville évincée
c'est surtout la clé bon ton le plus
alors ceux qui qui souffrent le plus de
la guerre on classe de 8e b on fait
aussi de la politique étrangère ce mr
mans
ils bombardent les pots pour que toute
la ville meurt et après eux plus plus
feront de guerre plus agrandi plus ils
vont agrandir leur pays alors ils vont
prendre le liban après ils peuvent
prendre des autres pays et tout ça pour
agrandir pour être le plus puissant fait
pour commander toute la terre
j'ai remarqué des magasins des immeubles
et des portes blanc garner et ben les
ont tiré dessus ça sert à rien de faire
la guerre venus 11 la station spatiale
soviétique vient d'atterrir en douceur
sur la planète du même nom la sonde a
commencé à transmettre des informations
à la terre sports demain départ du
rallye des sables paris dakar en auto en
moto ou en camion après un prologue hier
à montlhéry les 160 véhicules étaient
rassemblées aujourd'hui sous la tour
eiffel le départ sera donné demain matin
à 8 heures dans les jardins du trocadéro
le tiercé en ce jour de noël se courait
à vincennes pour gagner il fallait jouer
le 15 le 17 et le 18 combinaison qui
rapporte dans l'ordre le 672 francs 50
dans un ordre différent 110 francs pour
5 francs bien entendu et pierrette brès
hier dans ses pronostics avaient donné
ce tiercé gagnant noël passé il faut
maintenant penser au 1er janvier
la semaine sera à nouveau consacré à
l'achat de victuailles pour les
réveillons à venir et pas seulement en
france mais dans toute l'europe ou
parfois le 1er janvier est fêtée avec
plus de faste que noël en allemagne par
exemple notre correspondant permanent
michel meyer a remarqué que pour les
fêtes on avait acheté de plus en plus de
produits français la grande bouffe
version outre-rhin
l'allemagne pour les français c'est
encore le pays des énormités
rien n'y fera pas cette vision ni les
musiques populaires ni sur tous les
modes alimentaires de nos voisins
d'outre-rhin
les clichés ont la vie dure et il faut
bien dire que les allemands eux mêmes ne
font presque rien pour les démentis
c'est surtout le cas lors des ripailles
et beuvry défaite automnale de munich
il se fait cependant que le pays des
buveurs de bière impénitent et des
insatiable mangeur de charcuterie
connaît une véritable petite révolution
des moeurs sur le plan culinaire et
alimentaire c'est surtout vrai à l'égard
des produits mais surtout des vins
français
réalisant que nous avons gravi whitni le
poster du vent passé et l'année passée
nous en avons vendu 200 moutier ça veut
dire vous savez très bien que les
allemands aiment beaucoup la bière
éleveurs doux et maintenant on sait
faire le vin français plus sec et plus
arrondie avec beaucoup de buts il ya
quelques années que nous avons vendu la
quantité est seulement le prix est
maintenant nous vendons la délicatesse
des spécialités de toutes les piles et
si vous voyez cette semaine française
nous avons tellement de spécialités que
chacun peut essayer quelque chose
la jeune génération voyages beaucoup
pensaient que c'est l'allemagne
l'allemand est le monsieur qui voyagent
plus dans le moulin à vent l'amérique et
que depuis il a beaucoup vu beaucoup
vécu beaucoup retenu il n'y a jamais eu
à un moment plus propice pour vendre des
produits français sur ce marché étant
donné qu'on a réuni les conditions
suivantes le pouvoir d'achat et la haie
est très important deuxièmement les gens
sont de plus en plus de temps libre et
loisirs pensait que nous sommes ici à 35
heures par semaine bientôt et donc on
n'a jamais eu autant de temps ni
d'argent pour pouvoir se cultiver sur le
plan alimentaire essayé nous avons fait
nos fromages de france qui nous
importons chaque semaine deux voies nous
recevons c'est fromage dans du petit de
ferme et nous avons déjà de la clientèle
qui l'achètent que ces fromages là
parallèlement les restaurants français
grecs italiens et chinois ont depuis
cinq ans poussé comme des champignons
c'est en français par exemple manche
seafrance ont dîné il se prend des
tranches de deux heures et des allemands
mangent foot faux billets qui est pense
toujours en cross et les repas forcément
pour apaiser la faim et commencent
lentement à prendre que le dîner est
aussi les tentes
pas seulement pour manger c'est aussi
d'être faut s'entraîner c'est vrai
quelques 35 années de paix européenne
ont permis aux germains de découvrir les
douceurs voir les longueurs latine ils
apprennent à prendre le temps de vivre
c'est là un exercice qui leur est
toujours un peu fastidieux mais il
progresse sur la voie d'un décontraction
au point que des tables des temps durs
en place de plus en plus souvent les
cercles un peu guindée que forment dans
nos clichés mais aussi dans la réalité
les dames dévoreuse de gâteaux les
allemandes pour livre d'image dont
disent les mauvaises langues les
chapeaux ont été conçus par des
mécaniciens
l'histoire vraie qui va suivre peut
faire penser un conte de noël mais un
conte un peu triste il concerne le
dernier berger d'ajaccio ont pris lundi
du lait le berger chassés par la ville
ou le triomphe du béton gris sur l'herbe
verte voulais je suis le dernier berger
d'ajaccio le dernier frédéric collart
candide
ça veut dire le dernier qui reste
attrait moigne et qui porte à coup ne
mangent les hôpitaux belges epona savez
c'est mon pêche ça fait il faut dire que
je le courrier
j'ai connu ses parents son père et sa
mère
vous avez la propriété là j'étais au lit
planté des légumes tout ça c'était des
maraîchers et maintenant vous avez vu ce
qu'ils ont fait aux résidents sur des
crêtes au revoir à ce commando le
terrain comment j'ai toujours du béton
et total elle l'a surpris que ça se
passe un risque grave on était
tranquille et simon le pauvre maintenant
été obligé de sortir et de se faire une
petite bicoque à côté de faire le berger
et se défend comme il peut et bien moi
je vous dis franchement chapeau pour lui
il se met même panier sur la commune
pour pouvoir survivre et avec sa petite
bande de chèvres maintenant à b est ce
le soit j'ai compris le temps je suis un
peu de café pour la raison je suis un
peu des kpi qu'avant juste et c'est là
que je me trouve entouré de murs de
blockhaus
rozehnal ça va ça va ma vie des
quartiers chics russie quelques fiches
projets dans les parages à 10h loi
jean-marie 16h et maintenant tu défends
ma place qui gère le climat d âge
mais j'ai des rouges
je comprends que ce début à tout il m'a
même des figues de barbarie du mérite je
pense que c'est pas une honte de
vendredi les figues de barbarie
j'ai peut-être le dernier à chaque jour
et je crois que c'est le dernier l'ait
compris bon aure
j'aime aussi
allez
ils vont obliger de goûter au label
merci très bon
ac la saison longue délicieux france une
en il varie on les mange ça c'est un
très très bon et très bon c'est là où le
cui est meilleur je le vois on a des
complications lucky le cher on avait des
chiens on a des complications avec déjà
qu'ils aiment pas les bêtes l'échelle ça
les garages
alors si ça se construit encore un peu
plus en se demandant même à le jour que
je pouvais plus faire les relais bébé
est un type foutu j'aime trop les est
morte par là les chaînes continuent
encore ce camp français très tôt
je sais que j'avais une vue sur la mer
et métrage avec lui ce moment seul
regret que je voyais les et sanguinet
avec les finales qui se saluent mais de
temps en temps et c'était le charme que
j'avais dans ma maison les sorinières
sécuri la vue sur la mer pour les maths
aude qui rentrait qui sortait des
pêcheurs qui venait thierry des
feuillets qui discutaient qui chanter sa
chanson chantée les foules depuis des
dizaines d'années alors une fois de plus
allons-y avec plaisir poussons
l'escarpolette
m
et
on
ironique c'est l'ancêtre de la comédie
musicale c'est ça véronique oui c'est
l'ancêtre la comédie musicale comme la
plupart des opérettes français si on ne
considère pas le terme au père est une
façon péjorative
c'est un opéra comique dans la mesure où
la musique est d'une rare délicatesse
vous et musique très raffiné où
l'harmonie et ex triste et très
difficile à chanter mais le fait qu'ils
aient ce mélange de disciplines du texte
du champ c'est effectivement en france
que les américains ont refusé tout ça
retransmission télévisée d'une oeuvre
comme celle ci fait pour la scène
est ce que ça vous fait peur non pas du
tout pas du tout d'abord en 1h tellement
je vous dis rien ne me fait peur dans si
ce n'est qu'on sait déjà que les gens
viendront ensuite parce que tout ça est
presque plein c'est dire que des gens
ont envie de ce genre de spectacle le
gué 13 images d'epinal chatoyant c'est
un clin d'oeil au rétro en définitive
ainsi des gens à un petit peu trop
d'intelligences tient moderne faisait la
moue je serais ravi c'est que on aurait
réussi notre notre coup c'est très jeune
c'est gai c'est typiquement français à
mon avis dans le bon sens
ahmed
et
poussés
voilà véronique donc samedi à 21h30 sur
antenne 2 le temps demain sera beau et
ensoleillé et chaud pour la saison
quelques brumes et brouillards le matin
sur le sud ouest et le centre est des
nuages en soirée sur la vendée et la
breton vous avez rendez vous avec hervé
claude à 23h40 pour le dernier journal
fin de ce journal si avec betty dureau
et toute l'équipe qui l'a préparé je
vous souhaite de passer une excellente
soirée de noël
et puis bon courage si vous reprenez le
travail demain la semaine sera courte
car dès vendredi on recommence bonsoir
à